Transcriptor: Yonara Anastacio
Revisor: Analia Padin
¿Uds. cuál creen que sería el resultado
si en un buscador online cualquiera
pusiéramos la palabra “jugar”?
Miren lo que nos sale
en este buscador específico.
La gran mayoría son niños y niñas,
chiquitos menores de diez años,
jugando con pelotas de fútbol,
con plastilina, dibujando,
haciendo varias actividades.
Pero hagamos el mismo ejercicio
y busquemos la palabra “estudiar”.
Miren el cambio.
Nos salen personas mayores,
nos salen personas estresadas,
personas enterradas en libros,
personas que se ven como en equipo,
pero, en su gran mayoría,
tienen la cabeza agachada.
Y toda esta búsqueda nace de lo siguiente.
Y es que yo fui profesora universitaria,
todavía lo soy,
pero hace muy poco tiempo
empecé a estudiar nuevamente.
Y cuando empecé a estudiar nuevamente,
me empecé a sentir rara.
Empecé a sentir que algo no estaba bien.
Me empecé a sentir perdida.
No sabía muy bien
qué era lo que me estaba pasando.
Me sentía desubicada, no conectaba.
Todo el tiempo decía:
“¿Qué es esto? ¿Qué es esto
que me está pasando?“.
Y de repente llegó a mí esta cosa
que fue superclara y fue:
“Estoy recibiendo una educación
absolutamente clásica.
Estoy recibiendo
una educación tradicional,
estoy recibiendo una educación jerárquica,
y estoy recibiendo una educación
que uno esperaría recibir”.
Pero nada más allá de eso estaba pasando.
Eso mismo puede pasar con este ejemplo.
Y es un ejemplo que yo utilizo muchísimo
en mis clases y que me encanta ponerlo
y que hoy lo quiero hacer con Uds.
Y es: ¿cuál es la mitad de ocho?
La mayoría de las veces,
la respuesta que recibo
es que la mitad de ocho es cuatro.
Pero quiero que paren un segundo
y piensen un poquito más.
¿Qué otra podría ser la mitad de ocho?
La mitad de ocho podría ser un cero.
Podría ser un tres.
Podría ser una C. Podría ser una S.
Podría ser una E.
Podría ser una O y una C
o una H y una O.
Podría ser un ojo.
Podría ser un montón de cosas.
Y eso mismo que pasa
con este ejemplo del ocho,
es lo que pasa con la educación.
Y es que la educación
puede ser tradicional,
puede ser jerárquica,
pero también puede ser divertida.
Y también puede ser concebida
y puede ser entendida
a través del juego.
El concepto que vamos a ver a continuación
es el concepto de Homo ludens.
Fue acuñado hace muchísimos años,
en los años 30,
y hasta el día de hoy a mí me parece
que tiene un aporte gigantesco.
Y es que el Homo ludens lo que plantea
es que los hombres y las mujeres,
digamos como sociedad,
entendemos el juego
como algo que nos trae significado,
como algo que llena nuestra cultura,
como algo que nos muestra
distintas cosas de lo que está pasando
en la sociedad en la que vivimos.
Miren la siguiente búsqueda.
En este caso escogí Google Scholar
y puse las palabras “juego y educación”.
Miren cuántos resultados aparecen.
Estamos hablando de que hay
cinco millones 800 mil resultados
solamente en este buscador.
Son millones de resultados.
Hay resultados que datan desde 1970 y pico
1920, 1910.
Desde ese momento, ya se estaba hablando
de la importancia del juego
en la educación.
Se estaba hablando de la conexión
que existía entre el juego y la educación.
Pero, y esta es una pregunta
que quiero hacerle a todos,
piensen Uds. después
de su educación primaria,
¿cuántas veces los pusieron
a jugar para aprender?
¿Cuántas veces Uds. aprendieron jugando
en una clase de matemáticas,
en una clase de historia,
en una clase de sociales?
Más allá de Educación Física,
¿cuántas veces en su pregrado
sus profesores los pusieron a jugar?
En sus especializaciones,
en sus maestrías,
en sus doctorados, en sus trabajos.
¿Cuántas veces los han puesto a jugar?
La respuesta a veces es “Muchas veces”.
La respuesta a veces es “Muy pocas”.
La respuesta a veces es “Nunca”.
Yo he hecho esta pregunta varias veces
y, en mi experiencia,
la respuesta que más he recibido
es “Muy poquito”.
“Nos han puesto a jugar muy poquito”.
Y, muy posiblemente, la razón por la que
nos han puesto a jugar muy poquito
es porque el juego se interpreta y se ve
como algo que solo hacen los niños.
Pero aquí no solamente
cuenta mi experiencia.
Estamos hablando de que Harvard
está hablando de la importancia
del juego en la educación.
También el Lego Foundation está hablando
de cómo el juego y la educación
nos traen un montón de cosas positivas
en nuestras capacidades sociales.
También vemos cómo el Proyecto Cero,
que es una de las instituciones
más importantes en este tema,
nos muestra que no solamente
el juego sirve para los niños
sino también para los adultos,
y cómo, a través de jugar aprendiendo,
las consecuencias de ese aprendizaje
son mucho mayores.
Y vemos cómo esto avanza, crece,
se vuelve mucho más integral.
Y creo que hacia eso va la apuesta,
va hacia un aprendizaje
un poco más integral.
Y esto es solamente la teoría.
Pero creo que es importante
que vayamos a la práctica.
Y en la práctica vemos lo siguiente.
Entonces esta soy yo
parada en mi salón de clases
con una tormenta de fondo.
Y esa tormenta de fondo
no está ahí porque sí.
Esa tormenta de fondo está ahí
porque mis estudiantes
estaban haciendo un ejercicio
donde tenían muy pocos recursos algunos,
un poquito más de recursos otros
y un poquito más otros de ellos.
Y con esos recursos que tenían,
tenían que construir una tormenta.
Y esa tormenta tenía que ser fuerte
y tenía que ser poderosa,
y tenía que llamar la atención,
y tenía que asustar
como lo hacen las tormentas reales.
Pero ¿qué había detrás de eso?
¿Qué había detrás de esa tormenta?
¿Por qué pongo yo a estudiantes
de último semestre de Administración
a construir una tormenta?
Y es porque estaba
el concepto de recursividad.
Yo quería que aprendieran
acerca de la recursividad,
que aprendieran haciendo,
que aprendieran jugando
lo que significaba la recursividad.
Vamos a otro ejemplo.
Estos piratas que ven corriendo
estaban buscando un tesoro.
Una vez más, estudiantes de pregrado,
administradores listos para graduarse,
varios de ellos ya haciendo sus prácticas.
¿Por qué están corriendo
por toda la universidad
disfrazados de piratas?
No es Halloween; esto es en febrero.
Lo que estaban haciendo
era que en cada una de las pistas
que estos estudiantes estaban encontrando
estaban resolviendo diferentes desafíos
relacionados con el tema de la clase.
En este caso creatividad, innovación.
Estaban aprendiendo a través de pistas
que los llevaban a hacer
búsquedas en Google,
los llevaban a resolver crucigramas,
los llevaban a seguir instrucciones,
los llevaban a tener que buscar en lugares
en donde usualmente no buscarían cosas.
¿Todo con qué fin?
Con que aprendieran unos conceptos
que fácilmente hubiera podido enseñarles
en una clase magistral,
parada enfrente de ellos,
dictándoles lo que significaban.
Pero ¿qué se llevan ellos
cuando hacen algo,
cuando involucran su cuerpo,
cuando involucran una actividad distinta
a simplemente la sensación
de estar aprendiendo.
Acá no tenían esa sensación de estar
sentados en un salón de clase aprendiendo.
Tenían una sensación distinta,
que desde mi punto de vista
es mucho más valiosa
y es una sensación muy poderosa:
“Yo estoy haciendo algo diferente.
La estoy pasando bien
y eso no está impidiendo que aprenda.
Al contrario, me está ayudando
a aprender mejor”.
Este es un último ejemplo.
En este caso se trataba de
maximización de recursos.
Mis estudiantes tenían palitos de pasta
y un “marshmallow”.
Y tenían que hacer la torre más alta
solo con esas dos cosas.
Todos estaban compitiendo;
había competencia de por medio.
Y lo que yo veía en estos ejercicios
y en estas dinámicas es que, claro,
estaban aprendiendo a través de un juego
pero la estaban pasando bien
y, al final, las preguntas que surgían
eran mucho más que cuando yo antes
hacía ese ejercicio y solamente les decía:
“Venga, sentémonos y hablemos
de maximización de recursos”.
Las preguntas eran distintas.
La dinámica era distinta.
Su disposición para el aprendizaje
era distinta.
Y eso me lleva a esta sensación
de que hay un ciclo.
Cuando la educación es jerárquica
y el profesor esta acá,
y nosotros estamos acá,
y nuestros jefes están acá,
y nuestros estudiantes, empleados,
otra gente está abajo,
la comunicación es difícil.
Y si yo me pongo en los zapatos
de mis estudiantes por un segundo
y digo “Esta relación no es jerárquica,
esta relación es horizontal,
esta relación es un ciclo
en donde yo aprendo de ellos,
ellos aprenden a través del juego,
y en la medida en la que yo veo
cómo funciona este juego
aprendo cómo hacerlo diferente
para la próxima vez”,
estamos construyendo un sistema de
aprendizaje mucho más certero,
mucho más integral,
mucho más coherente
con el tipo de personas
que queremos sacar al mundo en el futuro.
Estamos construyendo unas personas
con un pensamiento que no solo se basa
en las expectativas tradicionales
de lo que es ser un estudiante
o un profesional.
Estamos sacando personas
que pueden divertirse
y pueden interpretar la vida
de una manera distinta.
Y suena muy fácil decirlo.
Suena muy grande.
Suena algo como:
“¿De qué me está hablando?“.
Pero los resultados y lo que yo he visto,
y no solo yo, lo que han visto
todas esas instituciones,
nos muestra que jugar es cosa seria.